the media have had a lot of fun pushing
unproved claims between Trump and Russia
okay now here's another angle that you
may not have seen claims the NRA has
been penetrated by the Russians somehow
as well Kim's drasil is on The Wall
Street Journal editorial board and she
joins us tonight I almost can't keep up
with the various things the left doesn't
like that they're claiming have been
penetrated by Russia but but unpack this
nutty conspiracy theory force if you
would well what's important about this
one Tucker is it's by the very same
people it would appear that brought us
the dossier claims as well so you
remember the Clinton campaign hires this
fusion GPS to Commission the dossier it
comes up with these fantastical dossier
claims and what's it do it goes to the
FBI in order to give them some
legitimacy even though nothing in it has
been corroborated nothing's been proved
and then once the FBI said it was doing
an investigation then everyone took it
seriously so now what we have is same
people fusion GPS that have been
peddling to the House Intelligence
Committee and others their argument glen
simpson the head of fusion gps that the
nra has quote been infiltrated by the
russians their top leadership and that
Russians have been filtering money
through the NRA and did during 2016 to
help Trump now he has no evidence for
this and yet we see the media running
after and suddenly lots of stories
making this claim without a shred of
evidence it has anybody I mean there are
some very smart people on the left and
some of them who are self-aware has
anyone said will meet us maybe this is
mass hysteria if everything we don't
like every popular movement we disagree
with if we if our instinct is to blame
unseen saboteurs from Russia maybe we're
crazy has anybody said that nope not
that I have heard of because as you know
and I know there is such an interest
right now on Russia somehow connecting
it to the Trump campaign suggesting
there are nefarious things happening
around every corner and this is just
very concerning because look there is
not one jot of evidence to this all
right Glenn Simpson said
this in testimony he mentioned some
random Russians names he could provide
no evidence of money transfers of any
persons name in the NRA who supposedly
took it and yet you have newspaper
outlets like McClatchy who continued to
run newspaper articles giving credence
to this so how does the NRA it has
flatly denied it anyone involved with
this is flatly denied it but apparently
all you have to do these days is come up
with a conspiracy have House Democrats
give it credence and then suddenly it's
legitimate our leaders are out of
control emotionally they're out of
control their children I'm see it scary
actually it's having a big effect
compacting for for explaining that to us
I appreciate your sober voice in the
middle of thank you on non-silver time